what do you think that boris johnson and  carrie johnson can expect when they  arrive at the front of of balmoral as  they're welcomed into the entrance  because they have been here before  haven't they yes they have been before i  believe yeah well i think the wonderful  thing about driving explore mall is that  drive up and just getting a sense of  the granite splendor of balmoral castle  because it it is a castle but it's quite  an intimate castle all the time um  and it's a place they have seen before  but  perhaps in different in different  weather conditions the atmosphere it is  a very place of  atmosphere and drama and we're seeing  louise now pictures of boris johnson uh  being met by sir edward young sir edward  young here and also said edward they're  shaking the hand of carrie johnson as  well